>>> WELCOME BACK TO "CBS THIS
MORNING SATURDAY."
WE BEGIN THIS HALF HOUR WITH A
STARTLING DISCOVERY MADE IN
HOUSTON.
POLICE FOUND DOZENS OF PEOPLE
CRAMMED INTO ONE HOUSE AND
LIVING IN POOR CONDITIONS.
SOME SHOWED SIGNS OF THE
CORONAVIRUS.
POLICE AND DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY ARE TRYING TO
DETERMINE WHO THOSE PEOPLE ARE.
OMAR VILLAFRANCA REPORTS.
>> Reporter: A 911 CALL LEADS TO
A SHOCKING DISCOVERY.
POLICE FOUND MORE 90 MIGRANTS
PACKED INTO A TWO-STORY HOME,
PART OF A HUMAN SMUGGLING RING.
>> THERE'S NO CHILDREN INSIDE.
THE YOUNGEST IS PROBABLY EARLY
20s.
AS OF RIGHT NOW, I THINK WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY FIVE FEMALES AND
THE REST ARE MALES.
>> Reporter: THE MIGRANTS
TELLING POLICE THEY WERE HUNGRY,
WHILE SOME WERE SHOWING SIGNS OF
COVID-19.
>> WE DO HAVE OUR HEALTH
DEPARTMENT EN ROUTE.
THEY WILL DO SOME RAPID TESTING
SO WE WILL KEEP THEM IN THE
HOUSE FOR NOW.
>> Reporter: NEIGHBORS HERE ARE
SHOCKED.
>> I JUST HOPE THAT AT FIRST
THEY'RE TAKEN CARE OF AND THEN,
I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW JUST HEALTHWISE,
HOPE THAT THEY'RE OKAY.
>> Reporter: THIS STASH HOUSE
DISCOVERY IS JUST ONE OF SEVERAL
MADE IN TEXAS THIS WEEK.
IN A SEVEN-HOUR PERIOD ON
WEDNESDAY, BORDER PATROL AGENTS
IN THE RIO GRANDE VALLEY RAIDED
FOUR HUMAN SMUGGLING STASH
HOUSES FINDING 52 MIGRANTS, ALL
IN ONE COUNTY.
ALSO ON THURSDAY, AGENTS FOUND A
STASH HOUSE IN 27 PEOPLE INSIDE,
BUT IT'S NOT JUST HOUSES THAT
ARE PART OF THE SMUGGLING RING.
A FEW HOURS LATER, AGENTS IN THE
RIO GRANDE VALLEY FOUND MORE
THAN 20 MIGRANTS HIDING IN THE
BACK OF AN